the shot clock  is  a second and a half ahead of the game  clock  jokic has it eight to shoot  we're tied at 127. yoket's doubled  he finds gordon gordon for three  [Applause]  aaron gordon from the corner  1.7 remaining did gordon get it off in  time  he did  what a shot by aaron gordon that pass  from nicola jokic  as he is double-teamed  [Applause]  nicole jokic records his tenth assist he  has got  another triple-double it was on dave  reed a technical foul on davon reed i  believe it was for being on the court  thinking that the time was out 130 to  128 in overtime 1.7 remaining  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  the ball is in luke  1.7 clippers have a chance for a heave  reggie jackson  [Applause]  they're going ballistic in the ball  aaron gordon comes up  with one of the biggest shots  of his nba career  and a sensational night for nicola jokic